another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation dr bright is not  allowed to feed anything with peanut  butter to kane and no we don't mean  scp-073 that's kane with a c this is dr  kane pathos crow a legendary scp  foundation researcher who through some  anomalous accident got turned into a dog  with human level intelligence and  ability dr bright is no stranger to  being an animal thanks to his body  swapping necklace so he may want to  treat his colleague to a nice spoonful  of peanut butter as an act of solidarity  after all peanut butter without xylitol  is safe for dogs to eat but no matter  how funny dr bright thinks it is the o5  council is not amused by the constant  sounds of dr crow trying to lick peanut  butter off the roof of his mouth during  staff meetings